I
[Music]
grateful you asked and you got it
[Music]
Rachel is our bachelor pad
first we got that promo then we got this
stunning Adam seriously Rachel Lindsay's
season of The Bachelorette cannot come
soon enough
I can't complain about that turns out
her bachelor co-star Corrine elympios
can't wait for it to start either
Rachel's amazing I love her she's done
my really good friend I'm so happy she's
the Bachelorette I think she's gonna
find the most amazing fiance soon-to-be
husband ever so excited for her because
there's a school of thought that like
well maybe she's to put together to be
the Bachelorette like she's an attorney
and she's a little older and she's so
maybe there won't be it won't be as
crazy I don't think anybody could be to
put together to be the Bachelorette I
think she's perfect she's funny she's
classy she knows when it where I just
shoot amazing
and hey maybe next year we'll get
Bachelorette corn would you do the
Bachelorette of course I would I mean
it's a wonderful opportunity for anyone
that gets offered it I mean it's amazing
you got to fall in love in the perfect
love story
you